to actually met him and join with him in
a they comic-con as I come and fight was
I mean who also would you want in your
corner
Michael has battled Parkinson's disease
since he was thirty years old
in the beginning he felt depressed and
turned to alcohol but shortly after
coming out publicly in 1998 he got a
message that the greatest of all time
wanted to speak with him telling NBC
News I got on the phone with him and he
was quiet for a while then he said in a
very soft voice I'm glad you're in this
fight with me and if you said formative
moment in my life that fight led to
Michael to create the Michael J Fox
foundation for Parkinson's research
which has so far invested more than 450
million dollars to find a cure
look again we see two people who won't
stop fighting until I secure a symbol
he's a symbol of fighting a peaceful
warrior I am a giant a giant that never
backed down from a fight and never tried
to forget the past they called Lonnie
his wife and I said there's no holly get
sad when he sees she get angry when he
seizes himself there's a young man
without the disease and she said no he
loves you watch it all day long